قالت سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي انها قصفت مدينه عسقلان
ومناطق غلاف غزه الشمالي برشقه صاروخيه
مركزه هذا واكدت بلديه عسقلان ان القبه
الحديديه اعترضت قذيفتين صاروخيتين صباح
اليوم في سماء المدينه وافادت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه بان رشقه صاروخيه كبيره اطلقت
من غزه كما سمع دوي صفارات الانذار في
عسقلان و جنوبي
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل ومتابعه معنا من غلاف غزه مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري نجوان اذا رشقه
صاروخيه جديده تستهدف غلاف غزه هل من
تفاصيل اضافيه
[تصفيق]
نجوان بالفعل وقد وصفت بانها رشقه
استثنائيه لا سما وانها تاتي بعد نحو
اسبوع دام ساد فيه الهدوء على في منطقه
عزقلان تحديدا شمال قطاع غزه هذه المره
الاولى التي تطلق فيها دفعه صاروخيه الى
منطقه عزقلان منذ اسبوع وبحسب بلديه
المدينه تم اعتراض قذيفتين صاروخيتين في
سماء عسقلان هذا الصباح بالاضافه الى ان
صافرات الانذار كانت قد دوت في بلدات عده
في منطقه غلاف غزه في الغلاف دوت ايضا
صافرات الانذار الليله الماضيه تحديدا في
منطقه بلده ديروت ومناطق اخرى وهذا الصباح
ايضا دوت في عدد من المناطق لكن حاليا
تقاس هذه الصواريخ التي تطلق من غزه اي
بعد هدوء معين لا سما واننا نتحدث عن اكثر
من 12 ع ساعه مرت منذ يوم امس دون اطلاق
للقذائف الصاروخيه بالنسبه للجانب
الاسرائيلي بطبيعه الحال وايضا بعد اسبوع
على اطلاق صواريخ الى منطقه عسقلان لكن
رغم ذلك فان الجهات الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن
انه بالرغم من ان الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن انه تمكن من ان الجيش
تمكن من تخفيض عدد القضائ الصاروخيه التي
تطلق باتجاه البلدات الاسرائيليه الى
قرابه الصفر وفقا لوصفه الا اننا ما زلنا
نشاهد ونشهد على اطلاق مزيد من القضائ
الصاروخيه رغم كل ما تتعرض له المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في داخل اي غزه لاسما وانه
عندما يتم الاطلاق ايضا من المناطق
الشماليه التي يتحدث الناطق العسكري عن
انه احكم سيطرته عليها بشكل شبه كامل دعنا
نشاهد ايضا
هذه الصور من المنطقه الشرقيه لبلده بيت
حانون هذا الخط الشرقي المتاخم
لشريط الحدودي من الجهه الشرقيه لغلاف غزه
نبدا من الجه اقصى اليمين هي بلده بيت
حانون وفي عدسه الكاميرا نتمكن من مشاهده
حجم الدمار الذي احدثته قوات الاحتلال في
كل تلك المناطق المتاخمه لبلدات الغلاف
غزه مرورا من بيت حنون الى الغرب منها تقع
ايضا بيت لاهيه لكن في الصوره ايضا
بامكاننا مشاهده سحب دخان ما زالت تتصاعد
من منطقه تحديدا حي التفاح وايضا منطقه
جباليا الواقعه الى الجنوب من منطقه بيت
حانون وبالتالي هذه المناطق كانت كان
الاحتلال قد بدا اجتياحه العسكري والعمليه
البريه الى داخل داخل غزه من هذه المناطق
بعد قرابه ثلاثه اسابيع عندما بدات الحرب
من قصف جوي عنيف وتدمير للمنازل والمباني
السكنيه والمنشات في كافه انحاء هذه
المنطقه لكن مما نرصده من الواضح بان
الاستهداف الاكبر لهذه المنشات ولهذه
المباني يطال تحديدا البيوت والمباني
السكنيه التي
تقع تحديدا عند و محاذاه الشريط الحدودي
سواء كان من النواحي
الشماليه بالقرب من منطقه بيت حانون ومعبر
ايرز ما يعرف بمعبر ايرز واذا ما جئنا من
هذه الجهه الشرقيه لهذه المناطق الشماليه
ايضا نرى بانه على طول خط الحدود هناك
عمليات تدمير واسعه للمنشات والمباني
السكنيه وحتى اننا في الايام الاخيره
الماضيه نرصد كذلك عمليات تفجير واسعه لما
لم يتم تدميره
من خلال عمليات القصف الواسعه سواء كان
بالمدفعيه او بالقصف الجوي هناك عمليات
تدمير واسعه لهذه المباني السكنيه تقوم
عليها وحده او سلاح الهندسه في جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وحتى ان الكثير من
الجنود والضباط يقومون بنشر صور وفيديوهات
لعمليات التفجير المتواصله لهذه المناطق
وهذا ايضا ما رصدناه ونرص في الم المناطق
الشرقيه لقطاع غزه في منطقه الشجاعيه
والمناطق الوسطى هو تدمير كبير والحديث
بطبيعه الحال يدور عن قضيه اقامه منطقه
عازله او حزام امني كما تسميه اسرائيل
داخل قطاع غزه للمرحله المقبله ما بعد
الحرب لكن الاخطر من هذا هو قضيه ما
يتزايد الحديث عنه في الايام الاخيره
الماضيه اسرائيليا
من قضيه ان اسرائيل لن تسمح لسكان الشمال
تحديدا بالعوده الى هذه المناطق وربما
عمليات التفجير المستمره لها علاقه ايضا
بهذا الامر مع ازدياد الحديث عن اعاده
الاستيطان الى هذه المناطق
وتهجير مئات الاف الفلسطينيين من غزه الى
دول اخرى يوم امس نشر موقع تايمز اوف
اسرائيل او زمن اسرائيل
مقالا قال فيه بان اسرائيل تجري اتصالات
متقدمه مع عدد من الدول من بينها الكونجو
من اجل اقناعها لاستيعاب
واستقبال اعداد كبيره من اللاجئين لكن في
ساعات المساء يوم امس سرعان ما تحدث مسؤول
كبير كما وصف في الصحافه الاسرائيليه
للصحفيين الاسرائيليين قال او نفى هذا
الخبر رغم ان نتنياهو بنفسه كان قد نقل
عنه وسمع وهو يتحدث في لجنه الخارجيه
والامن الاسبوع الماضي عن ان الحكومه تعمل
على ذلك وهناك اتصالات جاريه من اجل اقناع
دول لاستيعاب اعداد كبيره من اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين في المرحله المقبله من غلاف
غزه مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري شكرا جزيلا
لك الان